hallo ich bin's ali wer mich kennt der
weiß backen
nach morattis und murats große liebe
nach sally natürlich sind sie ließ
unwiderstehliche kreation 19 jahre
räuber den letzten neun jahren habe ich
30 kilo zu gelangen
der sonntag wird sich die neue wachs
sendung nicht einfach zum dreißigsten
september
nur bei vox
[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine richtig leckere
bromber schokoladentorte und ich glaube
wenn man die torte so anschaut dann
würde man sie auf jeden fall schon mal
nachmachen
hier unten habe ich einen richtig
schönen schoko bist wird mit bisschen
espresso dann eine schoko creme bromberg
rehm eine helle creme und abgeschlossen
das ganze nochmal mit pumpen
die torte ist von der zubereitung her
ziemlich einfach nur ein bisschen zeit
aufwendig weil man einfach immer wieder
geschichten kühlen muss und dann die
nächste schicht macht aber ansonsten ist
sie wirklich einfach ich werde jetzt
zuerst einmal den schoko biscuit
herstellen dafür verwende ich 200 gramm
zucker eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt 20 computer tonkabohne 40 grad
beta kuvertüre oder schokolade 100 gramm
mehl 20 kompakter und einen espresso für
den teig nämlich jetzt zuerst die eier
die kommen in eine rührschüssel ihr
könnt den teig natürlich auch ganz
normal mit einem handrührgerät verrühren
dann salz dazu zucker und vanille
geprägt
jetzt kann ich die masse für etwa fünf
bis sechs minuten richtig cremig
verrühren
in der zeit werde ich aber hier schon
heute schokolade schmelzen dafür nehme
ich jetzt einfach den heißen espresso
dann habe ich erst ganz frisch
rausgelassen und das sollte die hitze
auf jeden fall reichen für die
schokolade die schokolade ist jetzt auch
geschmolzen da habe ich jetzt noch die
butter dazu gegeben
und wenn sie dann nicht mehr ganz
schlimm ist weil die hitze schon weg ist
dann einfach kurz auf dem herd erhitzen
bei niedriger stufe
jetzt kann ich hier die schokolade
einrühren
[Musik]
hier kommen jetzt noch der tonkabohne
und prägt das von carbon lesen richtig
tolles gewürz müsst ihr auf jeden fall
mal ausprobiert und davon wirklich nur
ganz wenig fühle mich total ergebnis
dann das mehl 7 gemeinsam mit dem
kakaopulver und alles unterheben
kakaopulver bei uns sagt cacau
[Musik]
jetzt will ich die massen um einen bug
ring den habe ich bereits auf 20 cm
eingestellt und wenn ihr den kuchen
größer oder kleiner machen wollt könnt
ihr einfach auf meinem blog
vorbeischauen da könnt ihr die zutaten
nämlich ganz automatisch umrechnen
lassen
[Musik]
der kuchen ist komplett abgekühlt ich
habe ihn auch direkt aus der backform
herausgelöst und dann gestürzt und ihn
abgedeckt abkühlen lassen
jetzt wird die creme zubereitet bei der
creme ist es ja so ich möchte diesen
dreier effekt haben und die schokocreme
dann die bombe helle creme und oben
drüber dass geely das heißt für mich ich
bereite jetzt einmal eine grund maße zu
und teilen sie dann in drei teile und
bereitet dann jede masse für sich zu für
die schokocreme verwende ich dann noch
70 gramm zartbitterschokolade 50
milliliter wasser und zwölf gramm anlage
für die brummer creme brauche ich nur
100 gramm und die gleiche menge wasser
und agger und für die helle creme
brauche ich auch 50 milliliter wasser
und zwölf gramm ag jetzt kann ich zuerst
einmal die sahne steif schlagen
gemeinsam mit dem sommerbad
[Musik]
die sahne steif
jetzt kann ich hier in der schüssel noch
den quark verrühren und da könnt ihr
entweder magerquark benutzen oder
wenigstens lag weniger haben wollt auch
sahne quark den puderzucker streich
jetzt solch ein hase damit einfach die
klümpchen verschwinden aber wir haben ja
sagen würde bruder zugang
das kind immer gesagt gut sie schon
immer noch ein kind aber kurz verwehren
ich habe ich hier vorsichtig die sahne
unterheben
mit nämlich von dieser grundmasse etwa
400 gramm weg für die helle masse
jetzt stelle ich beide cremes in den
kühlschrank und bereits schon mal die
schokolade vor
und jetzt bei allen massen wichtig dass
er das engagement der wasser kochen dass
mindestens zwei minuten damit einfach
seine wirkung entfalten kann
ihr könnt natürlich auch gelatine nehmen
mit gelatine wird das ganze auch so ein
bisschen musiker und nicht so ganz
kompakt aber ich nehme einfach oft gerne
die pflanzliche variante also jetzt
verrührt und dann zwei minuten sprudelnd
kochen lassen mich nehmen dann hier die
schokolade und lasst sie einfach hier
drüber so ein bisschen im wasserbad
sozusagen erwärmen und schmelzen
das wird den murat jetzt natürlich
freuen so und 21 trick zum strom sparen
die schwäbische hausfrau nein badische
damit ist die schokolade jetzt nicht
ganz geschmolzen aber ich gebe es jetzt
einfach hier unten zum acker mit dazu
und je nachdem wie groß ein topf ist
also wenn sie einen zu großen topf nimmt
dann reicht die flüssigkeit bei mager
nicht aus dann ist einfach ein bisschen
mehr wahrzunehmen also nicht mehr was
man mit meerwasser
[Musik]
beim tortenboden habe ich bereits den
deckel abgeschnitten
den habe ich jetzt ein bisschen
zerbröselt daraus kann ich später
einfach kleine desserts machen oder
einen glas bisher
und hier habe ich es einen sauberen
torten bringt umgesetzt
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich von der übrigen creme also
von der großen masse die hälfte weg das
sind dann so etwa 300 gramm
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die schokocreme mit der
creme verbinden
dafür nehme ich aber zuerst einmal einen
teil der weißen creme damit einfach das
ak keine klümpchen macht und sobald es
dann temperiert ist kann ich das hier
dazu geben und vorsichtig unterheben
und dann ist da wirklich schnell
arbeiten weil das engagement anzieht und
recht wird
[Musik]
mit jetzt direkt auf den tortenboden
streichen und den tortenboden könnt ihr
wenn ihr wollt vorher noch trinken mit
etwas likör oder kaffee zum beispiel um
den tortenboden einfach ein bisschen zu
aromatisieren
und zum glattstreichen nämlich einfach
eine zeitkarte dann habe ich eine
richtig schöne ebene fläche und bevor
jetzt die branche darauf kommen aus der
kuchen oder die torte ist erstmal in den
kühlschrank damit die schicht festwirt
und ich später dann die schönen
einzelnen schichten habe sobald die
torte dann fest ist wird die bromberg
wem hergestellt und dafür für ihre ich
die aufgedruckten brombeeren mit dem
wasser und koch ist dann gemeinsam mit
dem agatha auf die masse muss jetzt auch
wieder zwei minuten lang sprudelnd
kochen das pubertäre muss dann auch
wieder lauwarm abkühlen bevor es mit der
creme verrührt werden kann
und auch hier gilt wieder erst ein
bisschen creme einrühren schön
temperieren damit keine flöckchen gibt
und stückchen und stand unter die
restliche creme heben
[Musik]
jetzt auch wieder zügig auf die creme
streichen und damit die torte später
wirklich perfekt aussieht könnt ihr
einen teig scharer nehmen den sauber
machen und dann hier am rand die ganze
creme die vielleicht ein bisschen
verschmiert ist einfach wegstreichen
[Musik]
dann wieder relativ zügig die creme
drauf streichen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die creme auch schön glatt und
die torte kann wieder für etwa eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank und dann
werde ich noch die helle creme zu
bereiten und dafür auch wieder wasser
und aka aka zwei minuten lang sport und
aufkochen lassen mit der hellen creme
verrühren und auch die helle creme über
der torte verstreichen für die letzte
schicht für ihre ich jetzt noch mal
aufgetaute brombeeren mit etwas wasser
jetzt werden die brombeeren mit dem
agatha vermischt und wieder zwei minuten
sport und gekocht die masse lasse ich
jetzt lauwarm abkühlen und hieß es sie
dann als letzte schicht über die torte
und jetzt muss die torte etwa drei
stunden kühlen
ich stelle sie aber jetzt über nacht
führen
[Musik]
meine torte durfte jetzt über nacht
kühlen aber drei bis vier stunden
reichen auch auf jeden fall aus jetzt
wird die torte noch fertig dekoriert
entweder schlag die jetzt einfach nur
sauer auf und macht obendrauf oder ihr
macht sich ich habe hier noch mal eine
bombe masse und zwar nehme ich jetzt
noch mal 100 gramm gefrorenen brombeeren
und koch ist solange ein bisschen
flüssigkeit verdunstet ist jetzt werden
hier noch die kern heraus gestrichen und
die masse muss dann eben kurz abkühlen
am besten im kühlschrank oder ihr lägen
darunter das ist echt immer ein super
tipp so kühlt immer alles relativ
schnell ab jetzt gebe ich hier noch
frischkäse dazu schmeckt richtig lecker
dann sahne butter zucker nach geschmack
[Musik]
und damit kann die masse steif
geschlagen werden
[Musik]
jetzt will ich die creme noch in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer großen stern
thüle und dies schön fein gezeigt bei
der torte kann ich jetzt den tortenring
ganz vorsichtig entfernen
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr einfach eine saubere
palette und streicht einmal so entlang
und jetzt gleichmäßiger auf spritzen und
die bergen ich nehme jetzt brummbären
wieder auf tiefkühlfach weil er gerade
keine brummbär zeit ist die sätze ich
dann erst kurz vor dem verzehr auf mit
einem ins plätzchen
[Musik]
seid ihr bereit für die torte das rote
ich weiß wie so eine fürst pückler torte
die machen wir auch mal kennt ihr alle
hatte ich geb dir ja wahrscheinlich alle
dieses fürst pückler eis dieses
sandwiches mit den drei schichten
guckt mal schön kalt gefrierfach war
nächste mal probieren sollte man aber
auch mal mit alles machen nochmals so
lecker schmeckt ja auch mit brombeeren
ich probiere auch mal ich glaube halt
vor allem die einzelnen schichten wenn
man jetzt nur die unteren zwei probiert
dann hat man einfach eine schokotorte
und dann kommt das fruchtige obendrauf
die armut jetzt schon im mund aufgemacht
voll gut oder sonst die leute nach
machen unsere zuschauer dass die anderen
auch machen
die torte droht also falls ihr die torte
die von samira und erprobt und probiert
wurden auch nach machen möchtet dann
findet ihr das rezept auf salehs blog.de
und schmeckt die torte sehr gut und vor
allem ist er optisch wirklich ein
highlight probiere das rezept gerne aus
ihr findet sie auch paris - blog.de und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wieder bis zum nächsten
mal
ich finde cremen also zuerst diese rote
sticht hier knusprig ist kein held ich
auch und das ist echt auch auf der gabel
voll hübsch aus
[Musik]
neu bei gosee ist der größte stern im
bug universum in meiner neuen sendung
verraten spieler neue rezepte tipps und
tricks
mit sally wird der sonntag einfach
herzhaft
[Musik]
einfach sitzen mit sally wird das spaten
einfach einfach
mein fahrstil ab 30 september
beim kochen